le même délit c'était un arrêt important
pour le Premier ministre Trudeau en
pleine campagne électorale il y a deux
ans
a été reconnu pour la qualité de ses
viandes fumées de ces fameux Smokies il
était situé juste en face d'un autre
établissement semblable chez soi si
j'avais envie d'être poussé pressé et
avoir l'ambiance de schwarzialer là mais
la plupart du temps j'avais tendance à
traverser la rue être calme confortable
et le smoking était tous aussi bien chez
Schwarz justement Joao le cuisinier
depuis plus de 40 ans ne voyait pas le
même délit d'en face comme un
compétiteur il était des bons amis puis
ils avaient leurs clients on avait nos
clients
moi je dis que c'est ici c'est ici même
délit ouvert en 1974
des clients fidèles c'était cute parce
que il y avait toutes sortes de coupures
de presse là ça s'était comme par
exemple Cohen la Narc Cohen le fameux
qui disait c'était la meilleure smoke
mieux que chez soi mais c'est triste
c'est triste lors d'un hommage Leonard
Cohen a un gala de la disque son fils a
fait allusion la fréquentation de son
père au restaurant mène délit le smokeek
du Schwartz
le smoke du main il a il préférait celui
du même
une fermeture soudaine et sans
explication de la part du propriétaire
du restaurant Le Maine daily aurait eu
50 ans l'an prochain c'est un autre lieu
légendaire de Montréal qui disparaît ici
Jacques bissonner Radio-Canada Montréal